non vous cautionnez quatre mois comme
avocat vous imaginez je peux pas porter
de jugements négatifs vis-à-vis de mon
client il m'a choisi comme avocat
justement c'est là on en revient à cette
vidéo à se lier à ce texte à tout ce que
j'ai fait jusqu'ici c'est à dire un
véritable engagement extrêmement radical
j'assume complètement contre un régime
que je considère dangereux et à partir
de là à partir de là un désir de la part
de pilotes pole dance kids défendu par
quelqu'un dont il savait qu'elle ne
lâcherait pas largués mais c'est
dégueulasse ça a été mine de rien c'est
dégueulasse ce de sortir des vidéos
comme ça privé vous pouvez pas
cautionner ça moi je suis tellement
gentille avocat
c'est dans une société où tout est paré
pour nos graphiques à commencer par des
émissions comme celles ci n'ont pas ne
se pose pas tant que cela n'aura
question qui se pose pour murat ça avant
tout de savoir enfin nous qu'est ce que
je dois faire en tant qu'avocat pour
éviter qu'un client se retrouve en
difficulté c'est mon seul rôle en tant
qu'avocats nous aider étiez très proche
des structures de gestion courant de la
faire avant qu'il allait sortir les
vidéos évidemment c'est d'ailleurs le
bâtonnier donc le chef des avocats à
paris
dans son avis m'a dit évidemment vous
avez rejouer un rôle de conseil
juridique ou les prévenus des risques
d'accord qu'il qu'il est vous l'avez
petit et sortir des vidéos et non plus
tôt l' inverse
j'ai essayé dans c à vous arrêter et ne
pas l'effrayer l'intimité de quelqu'un
jamais à au pire j'ai révélé des
rapports de népotisme entre des
personnes qui avaient des histoires
comme maria et donc vous crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est important que ça
prenait football dit non vous avez
essayé de dissuader de sortir ces vidéos
à l'algérie dit déjà annoncé très clair
dès le début j'ai fait un avis juridique
au jeu dit écoutez il ya un risque
notamment pénale du fait de la diffusion
de ces vidéos j'ai dit vous devriez
essayer contacté des journalistes vous
devrez essayer de contacter des joints
et ce qu'ils vont essayer de traiter
l'information qui vont par exemple dire
écoutez en effet il ya une différence
entre les discours des marges malgré ou
parce qu'il faut quand même rappeler
qu'au départ c'est sa démarche était
très bon oui et ses actes c'est à dire
qu'il met en scène sa famille dans gala